une centrale thermique gravement
endommagée victime de la stratégie russe
de destruction des infrastructures
énergétiques les habitants de dignepro
dans l'est de l'Ukraine sont à présent
privés d'électricité ce qui n'entame pas
leur détermination c'est frappes ne
changeront pas notre attitude peut-être
que nous ne ferons que les détester
davantage
ce préféré rester assise dans le froid
sans eau ni électricité plutôt que
d'être en Russie
un tiers des centrales électriques du
pays auraient été détruite depuis 10
jours une situation qui fait craindre un
hiver particulièrement Ruth pour les
civils des attaques répétés menées par
l'armée russe avec selon les autorités
ukrainiennes des drones fournies par
l'Iran un partenariat dénoncé par le
président elenski malgré le démenti du
Kremlin
le fait même que la Russie fasse appel à
l'Iran pour une telle aide et la
reconnaissance par le Kremlin de Safate
militaire et politique
d'après les observateurs la stratégie
russe data contre les infrastructures
stratégiques s'explique par les défaites
essuyées par le Kremlin depuis début
septembre l'armée russe perd du terrain
dans le Nord et l'Est du pays une donne
militaire délicate que le général
surovitine nouveau commandant des
troupes russes en Ukraine a reconnu à
demi-mot à la télévision
la situation dans la zone de l'opération
militaire spéciale peut être qualifiée
de tendue
l'ennemi n'abandonne pas ses tentatives
d'attaquer les positions des troupes
russes
la situation dans la région de Herson
n'est pas simple
personne une ville sous contrôle russe
mais qui pourrait être reconquise par
Kiev dans les prochains jours
l'administration prorus local a appelé
les habitants à évacuer la région